marseille ville de près de 900 mille
habitants connue pour son vieux port sa
bouillabaisse et son club de football
mais c'est aussi et c'est moins de leurs
yeux la ville la plus sale de france
bouteilles sacs en plastique emballages
cartonnés tout un tas de détritus
jonchent les trottoirs
beaucoup de riverains eskimos
aujourd'hui vivre dans une ville
poubelle vous passez dans les petits tas
de petites rues il ya les poubelles au
coin de la rue vous trouvez des rats
morts le matin il ya des trous enfin
voilà c'est la façade pour les touristes
avec des restaurants super chic et puis
les rues adjacentes elles sont elles
sont dégueulasses montmartre est
historiquement a toujours été une ville
de très sales bon c'est pas la seule
ville de france qui est concerné par
cette problématique
les cv qui est aussi nocive il nie aussi
également tout ce qui est lié au respect
du lieu
il suffit de voyager un peu pour
s'apercevoir qu'en france on n'est déjà
pas très propre pas très civilisé
et on n'a pas tendance à chercher une
poubelle pour jeter un papier et
marseille encore moins qu'ailleurs faut
reconnaître aussi que les gens ne sont
pas forcément propres eux mêmes il faut
pas avoir honte de le dire c'est à dire
quand on voit déjà un peu fumeux
que j'étais les paquets qui jette les
mecs vont voir les gens qui mange un
sandwich debout depuis dix ans et le
papier il ya aussi un manque de
de la part des marseillais de recherche
de propreté quoi ah oui c'est très sale
surtout moi je peux marseillaise et on
arrivera ici ça va choquer ouais des
poubelles constamment là éparpillés dans
la rue fin oui assez impressionnant
quand même entre incivilités des
marseillais et inefficacité des services
publics les torts serait donc partagés
mais pour aussi éducateur dans le monde
associatif les quartiers nord sont
particulièrement délaissées quand on
marche on marche ces pièces et pleins de
détritus
c'est plein d'ordures ménagères et puis
et puis avec le vent avec le mistral ça
arrête pas de se disputer un peu de
partout où on va
dans le premier le deuxième le troisième
arrondissement
ça ça tout toutes les heures où tous les
toutes les 45 minutes
ça passe pour nettoyer il ya les
beignets de la benne à ordures qui sont
là pour pour nettoyer il ya tous ceux
nécessaires qui est prêt en qui mis en
place après vous fur et à mesure que
vous vous décalez vous écarter de
l'épicentre de marseille ça devient
moins en moins accessible on a tendance
à la laisser à l'abandon un petit peu
tous ces secteurs-là qui a qui ne nous
correspond pas c'est à cette personne à
ses élus entre guillemets le vieux port
n'est pas épargné par l'insalubrité en
2010 9 7 tonnes de déchets ont été
repêchés des eaux
une pollution qui a forcément un coût
pour l'environnement
alors pour tenter d'éradiquer ce fléau
plusieurs pistes sont envisagées
certains souhaitent la création d'une
police de l'environnement qui
sanctionnerait toute personne auteur de
dépôts de déchets sur la voie publique
d'autres estiment qu'il faut plus de
moyens augmenter le nombre de poubelles
et de toilettes publiques et mettre en
place des actions de sensibilisation à
la gestion des déchets
[Musique]